non
attentat ou accident le dc10 d'uta n'a
pas encore livré son secret il y a très
peu de chances de retrouver vivant l'un
des 171 passagers
le budget 90 ou signes de la croissance'
invité de notre journal le nouveau et
l'ancien ministre des finances pierre
bérégovoy et edouard balladur
durcissement dans le conflit peut jours
chacun campe sur ses positions
à mulhouse il ya eu d'affrontements
entre grévistes et non grévistes des
moyens financiers exceptionnels pour les
sinistrés de guadeloupe dès samedi les
premiers versements pour les secours
d'urgence
bonsoir le mystère du vol ut 772 il
s'agit bien sûr du dc 10 de la compagnie
ut à qui s'est écrasé dans le désert peu
après son décollage de djamena il leur
est pratiquement aucun espoir de
retrouver des survivants parmi les 171
passagers et membres d'équipage alors
accident aux attentats impossible de le
dire ce soir
dans l'après midi il y avait une quasi
certitude l'avion aurait explosé en vol
alors tout de suite nous allons
retrouver les au téléphone en direct
avec nous à n'djamena notre
correspondant françois corner notre
envoyé spécial françois cornet qui a
survolé tout à l'heure le lieu de
l'accident font soir qu'est ce que vous
avez vu il était pris que dc 10 sont
éparpillés sur une zone d'environ 100
kilomètres carrés en plein désert à 400
km à l'est d'agadez et 220 consultants
est de l'arbre du ténéré en survolant à
basse altitude en fin d'après midi cette
zone du crash je n'ai vu que quelques
morceaux de l'appareil partie du
fuselage ou de la dérive arrière le
capot du réacteur 2 que des ciels
quelques corps seulement et un peu plus
loin une grosse tache noire sur le sable
le point d'impact de la plus grosse
partie du dc-10 ayant percuté le sol est
ce que ça veut dire n est rien presque
rien
la carlingue a été volatilisé le volutes
et 772 ne laisser que quelques traces
seulement et pour peu qu'une tempête de
sable se lève dans le ténéré le désert
pourrait définitivement engloutir ceux
qui restent visibles et maigre débris
françois j'imagine que ce que vous avez
vu c'est à dire les débris très
éparpillé font penser qu'il y avait eu
une explosion en vol mais abandonnée là
la vaste zone de 10 km sur 10 dans
laquelle sont dispersés les débris
l'hypothèse en effet de l'explosion en
vol semble la plus vraisemblable on n'a
pas beaucoup ce soir n djamena alors je
peux vous dire aussi que trois
hélicoptères puma du dispositif épervier
était cet après midi sur place et près
d'eux je n'ai vu que quelques corps
seulement rassemblé 7 et il ya moins
d'une demi heure trois quarts d'heure
environ
d'après vous françoise qu'il pourrait y
avoir tout de même des survivants
écoutez ici il est il de répondre
catégoriquement non et il est encore
plus difficile de répondre
peut-être peut-être y at-il des
survivants les vielles les corps ont été
éparpillés je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
sur une centaine de kilomètres carrés il
faut donc avant tout pour attiser il
faut du monde
il faut du matériel il faut des hommes
et pour l'instant ce n'est pas évident
d'envoyer des gens là bas
pour l'instant les militaires envoyés
trois fume à genève était assis
détachement il faut donc avant de
répondre oui ou non à tisser
complètement cette vaste zone
mais ce qui est train je voulais dit
tout à l'heure et de vente simple qui
pourrait se lever et 6e rang de simple
seule elle engloutit les recours les
mesures niveau où les gens blessés qui
ne peuvent pas se déplacer
et bien ce moment là je pense qu'il ne
faudrait plus de garder le moindre
espoir
merci françois je vous rappelle que
françois corner était notre envoyé
spécial au tchad il a pu cet après-midi
survolé l'épave et les morceaux
dispersés de l'appareil et il nous
téléphoner aussitôt à son retour de nous
amène à nous allons revenir dans un
instant aux différentes hypothèses
mais tout d'abord le drame tel que l'ont
vécue heure par heure les parents ou les
amis des passagers dominique verdeilhan
toute la nuit ils ont attendu guettant
tout singh qui pouvait leur redonner
espoir concernant le sort d'un des leurs
pourtant certains dell annonce
officielle de la disparition du dc-10 il
n'y avait plus aucune chance de survie
pour les passagers du vol ut 772 on
apprend que le vol retardé pour 15
minutes
si c'est pas trop grave nous sommes
habitués que pour ensuite tourner cinq
minutes
voilà je suis allé voir des
les responsables tu me diront ah non ils
ont perdu contre la lazio ne savent pas
du tout ce qui se passe ces terrains
nous a laissé entendre que ce soit un
crash soit un document d'avion ou bien
bon une panne va bien et vous mêmes
quels sentiments vous avez je peux pas
vous dire tout ce que je sais c'est que
j'ai
nous
moi j'ai peur chauffeur ce n'est que 13
heures plus tard qu'ils apprendront de
la bouche même d'un membre du thé à ce
qu'est devenu le dc10 j'ai appliqué un
art où venaient des plis sur une surface
pas facile d'accès le dc10 avait quitté
brazzaville à 9h15 sans incident après
une escale à n'djamena l'avion redécolle
avec à son bord 156 passagers et 15
membres d'équipage
il se dirige vers paris où il est
attendu à 19h10 la météo est bonne la
tour de contrôle de l'aéroport de
n'djamena est en liaison avec l'appareil
pourtant 45 minutes après le décollage
le dc10 disparaît des écrans
la tour de contrôle de niamey ne
rentrera jamais en contact avec le
commandant de bord la région où le dc10
a été retrouvée le massif de termites
dans le ténéré d'une zone sableuse
caillouteuse difficile d'accès les
parachutistes ont été les premiers à
arriver sur les lieux
ils seront suivis de plusieurs
commissions d'enquêté composée entre
autres de membres de la compagnie
aérienne et de la direction générale de
l'aviation civile
deux coups de téléphone à des agences de
presse ont revendiqué l'explosion au nom
du djihad islamique mais les policiers
n'ont pas pu authentifier ces
revendications et mystère demeure
toujours et d'ailleurs je vous le disais
il n'y a pas de certitude ce soir alors
voyons les différentes hypothèses avec
yves dumez
quand on parle de dc 10 on revoit des
filets une longue série de catastrophes
en 74 au dessus de la forêt
d'ermenonville un appareil de la turkish
airlines explose après le décollage une
porte de soute
c'était déverrouiller tout seul de
nombreux autres accidents ou incidents
mécaniques plus ou moins graves ont
marqué ses débuts mais encore
dernièrement le moteur arrière d'un
dc-10 explosé
le pilote réussi à poser son avion dans
des conditions dramatiques certes mais
au moins il sauva plus de la moitié des
passagers
il y a quelques jours l'administration
fédérale de l'aviation américaine a
découvert des fissures sur des arbres
deux moteurs un moteur identique à ceux
du dc 10 d'uta
en conséquence la f1 a ordonné hier la
vérification de tous les moteurs
construits par general electric aux
états unis pour ce type d'avion le dc10
d'uta acheté en leasing en 73 avait
effectué 60 mille heures de vol ce qui
est peu pour les spéciales
en outre l'appareil avait subi il y a
deux ans une grande visite c'est à dire
que tout est même le moindre boulon
avait été vérifié toujours est il que
les pilotes sont formels en cas de
problème même grave en vol il aurait
toujours le temps et la possibilité de
lancer un sos
ce qui n'a pas été le cas le problème
technique n'est pas complètement exclu
mais peu probable
alors reste la thèse de l'attentât c'est
même la première raison retenue par le
syndicat des pilotes de ligne du téat
je crois que les tous les moyens de
sécurité n'avait été mise en oeuvre en
particulier depuis lé début de l'année
où certains éléments de sûreté nous
aller à bord ont été supprimés ce serait
pour des raisons d'économie que la
direction du téat avait adopté un plan
de sécurité allégée en février dernier
ce que réfute bien sûr la société
nous avons renforcé le dispositif de
surveillance sur recommandation du
ministère de l'intérieur en faisant
appel à une société qui nous d'ailleurs
qui d'ailleurs nous avait été indiqué
par un des personnages du ministère
l'intérieur et on a redéployé ou
réorienter ce dispositif de sécurité sur
les conseils du ministère oui pour
l'instant ce sont les inspecteurs de
l'aviation civile qui devront déterminer
la véritable cause de cette catastrophe
leur attente a peut-être mais on peut
s'étonner tout de même en raison du lieu
est aussi par exemple de la compagnie
aérienne d'autant que les tensions dans
la région s'étaient apaisées récemment
tout cela ne plaide pas vous le voyez
pour cette thèse de l'attentât
bernard benyamin pourquoi un tel
attentat en effet alors que si l'on s'en
réfère à la zone concernée
il est tout juste vingt jours le tchad
et la libye fêter leur réconciliation et
que la france a déjà commencé à réduire
son dispositif militaire au tchad
côté iranien pourquoi un tel attentat
alors que le président iranien race
anjani semble vouloir rompre son
isolement diplomatique qu'il recevait
pas plus tard qu'hier à téhéran le
secrétaire général du quai d'orsay
monsieur françois cher et qui l'affirmé
solennellement tous les deux la volonté
des deux pays de réactiver leur relation
côté syrien enfin pour cointat l'attend
alors qu'au liban là encore le climat
est plutôt à la détente et que la france
étudierait actuellement la fin de la
mission de la flotte française au large
du liban
alors alors s'il ya effectivement
attentat on trouvera toujours un groupe
une organisation pour s'attaquer
un avion civil français précisément pour
donner un coup de frein à cette
politique de détente
c'est vrai par exemple qu'il existe en
afrique une filière chiite qui voient
d'un mauvais oeil la politique de
modération de lit
à l'égard de la france qui n'aime pas
beaucoup c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire l'intérêt que la france porte au
liban et qu'il est sans doute plus
facile pour ces gens-là de monter un tel
attentat en afrique plutôt qu'en europe
bref le pire est toujours possible et en
matière de terrorisme
malheureusement les fanatiques de tous
bords ne manquent pas tous là encore une
fois s'il y a eu effectivement attentats
merci bernard et l'instant même
j'apprends parfaite dépêche ce que l'on
pressentait depuis cet après midi déjà
est ce que nous a confirmé pratiquement
françois corner il n'y a pas de
survivant le commandant qui organise les
secours a dit tout à l'heure qu'il n'y a
aucune des 171 personnes qui se
trouvaient à bord du dc 10 d'uta n'a pas
survécu à la catastrophe
c'est officiel mardi voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire donc ce soir sur cette
catastrophe de l'avion du thé à une
fusillade très violente à toulon cet
après-midi auld qui a mal tourné et les
gangsters se sont enfuis les policiers
ont tiré bilan trois gangsters tué et un
policier blessé
patrice voler notre correspondant s'est
rendu immédiatement sur place
fusillade en plein champ la fuite a mal
tourné un mort ici dans les vignes deux
autres au bout de ce chemin là où s'est
arrêté là 309 des gangsters me crever
encerclés par la police après des
kilomètres de fuite au hasard des
dizaines de coups de feu et deux prises
d'otages dont un membre des forces de
l'ordre
le témoignage d'un des enquêteurs lancés
à la poursuite des truands steve o
cotation faut pas laisser passer comme
ça je l'avais vu la ligne arrêtée sur la
géologie la sphère a débuté vers 15h30
les trois hommes tentent un braquage et
s'enfuit à pied avec le caissier en
otage puis ils vident un bus de ses
passagers première fusillade un policier
blessé
nouvelle fuite vers carqueiranne jusqu'à
la fin tragique trois morts pour 80
mille francs des truands connu des
services de police ce soir l'enquêté
s'oriente vers le milieu corse les
moyens financiers exceptionnels pour les
sinistrés de guadeloupe c'est ce qu'a
annoncé ce matin le ministre des dom-tom
à l'issue du conseil des ministres dont
il est aussi le porte parole avant le 18
octobre on saura les modalités précises
d'indemnisation et puis dès samedi les
premiers versements de secours d'urgence
interviendront pour les communes les
plus touchées pour certaines communes
détruite à 90%
c'est vraiment nécessaire nous envoyés
spéciaux rémy roche et pascal stelletta
ont suivi les sauveteurs et les
militaires dans leurs opérations
reportage
la maison était perché en haut d'une
colline aujourd'hui elle ne ressemble
plus qu'à une sinistre des charges vous
avez reçu quelque chose dont vous
actuellement quelqu'un est venu pour
au point de vue sommes ici là il ya vous
aimez aller vers oui et j'ai dix enfants
puisque n'a pas ses enfants bien le
maximum le maximum sera fait surtout sur
moi ratifié
en contrebas on dégage la petite route
les grands axes de l'île eux ont déjà
tous été déblayé les hommes sont
exténués
les gens sont à temps saturé on arrive à
la première semaine très peu le repos
entièrement complet toujours sur le
chantier il faut maintenant compte tenu
de l'ampleur des dégâts augmenter
l'effectif mais sur place il n'y a plus
l'urgence de sauver des vies humaines
mais la guadeloupe est transformée en un
gigantesque chantier
la tâche est immense les ces cours sont
en place mais encore dérisoire plan
orsec coordonné par le préfet mise en
oeuvre par l'armée 700 militaires
renforcées par 400 personnes venues de
métropole
cela fait en tout 11 cents hommes on
pense qu'il en faudrait 5 fois plus
ans bertrand au nord-ouest de grande
terre 85% des habitations décapités ou
complètement détruite
ceux qui ont tout perdu sont hébergés
chez des voisins ou à l'école et les
réserves d'eau potable sont maintenant
épuisé il hier soir ils m'ont donné une
tasse de lait avec du pain dit cette
femme à midi ils m'ont donné du riz
vous n'êtes même pas faire moins bien
dans des secours un lit pour me coucher
combien de temps faudra-t-il pour panser
les plaies
un mois déjà simplement pour déblayer et
sans doute un an avant que la guadeloupe
retrouve l'apparence de son visage
normal
le bras de fer se poursuit dans le
conflit peugeot à mulhouse et à sochaux
le maire de mulhouse jean-marie bockel a
rencontré le patron de peugeot jacques
calvet et à la sortie de cet entretien
monsieur bockel s'est déclaré très déçu
à mulhouse
la journée a été marquée par des
affrontements dans l' usine entre
grévistes et non grévistes
tout se passe comme si chacun direction
d'un côté syndicats de l'autre durcit
fait sa position françoise joly à
mulhouse eux sont grévistes en face des
piquets de grève pour la première fois
le complètement l'accès du zoo
l'affrontement sera prête mais violent
de grévistes
légèrement blessé et évacué en ambulance
et pourtant ce matin aucun incident les
deux camps avaient même semble-t-il des
préoccupations à ses proches
moi je peux pas la faire la gueule parce
que moi aussi je fais la grève j'aime
autant vous dire déjà que je suis très
mal vu par ma maîtrise on va pas me
louper ça j'aime autant vous le dire je
me retrouve à la porte et qu'une lettre
de licenciement
alors moi j'ai une femme et une gamine
est élevé mais vous savez combien j'ai
après 15 ans d'ancienneté je bande de le
dire je peux vous le dire j'ai 5400
balle par mois et tous les matins je me
lève à 3h mais pour gagner ma croûte
mais cet après midi c'est non grévistes
prêt à rentrer coûte que coûte dans
l'entreprise ont un rôle un peu
particulier bonjour tu poses rentrée ils
sont cadres agents de maîtrise mais
surtout chargé par la direction
d'assurer la sécurité dans les usines
depuis le début du conflit
pour le syndicat ces incidents sont des
provocations des manoeuvres
d'intimidation de la direction comme
toutes ces lettres qu'elle a envoyé à
plusieurs salariés d'une usine de
mulhouse
j'ai exactement 14 lettres dont une qui
est pour un motif de licenciement et 13
autres pour des motifs
de mesures disciplinaires à l'encontre
des salariés dont une également sur les
quatorze qui vient d'un délégué du
personnel
pour la direction ces lettres
d'entretien préalable sanctionne des
atteintes à la liberté du travail voire
à la sécurité dans l'entreprise
bref ce conflit de plus en plus
l'ensemble s'installer dans la durée un
milliard deux cents millions de français
le montant du budget 90 le chiffre ne
vous dit peut-être pas grand-chose
alors voyons les grandes lignes de ce
budget du côté des recettes c'est-à-dire
du côté de ce qui rentre dans les
caisses de l'état
et bien certains impôts seront réduits
on vous l'a déjà dit du côté des
dépenses de l'état quelques changements
avec des nouvelles priorités ce sont
l'éducation le logement la recherche la
culture nous allons commenter tout cela
dans un instant avec notre invité le
ministre de l'économie pierre bérégovoy
met tout de suite les données chiffrées
des budgets qu'arsenal l'état aura l'an
prochain les coudées franches ces
crédits progressent compte en effet
sensiblement de 5,3 pour cent certains
ministères seront particulièrement bien
doté l'éducation nationale la recherche
le logement social
ils sont jugés prioritaires mais surtout
on ne lésinera pas sur les crédits de
personnel l'administration offrir à 7000
postes de plus des postes d'enseignants
ou de gendarmes notamment
côté recettes budgétaires les impôts des
français baisseront de près de 17
milliards de francs
avec d'abord un bonus donner aux
entreprises grâce à une réduction de
l'impôt sur les bénéfices réinvestis
autre volet fiscal l'harmonisation
européenne avec des baisses de tva sur
l'automobile principalement et une
taxation de l'épargné plus douce les
plus gros épargnants subiront en
revanche un alourdissement de l'impôt
sur la fortune et perdront certain
avantage sur les investissements
locatifs
enfin une innovation pour les
particuliers la taxe d'habitation sera
limitée elle sera plafonnée à 4 % du
revenu imposable
voilà je crois je me suis trompé en vous
donnant les chiffres là le montant du
budget c'est bien 1200 milliards de
francs voilà alors philippe sassier on
disait que ce budget allait être très
très difficile à admettre
harang terminé pardon et puis la
croissance est venue bien à propos pour
aider nos grands argentiers la m
et décroissance en effet ce budget a été
préparée sous la triple contrainte de
respecter les grandes priorités de la
lettre aux français
éducation nationale recherche logement
social notamment d'adapter notre
fiscalité à l'europe et de mieux
partager la croissance si la première
contre un qui préparent l'avenir et
développe la solidarité récolte à gauche
comme à droite
davantage d'applaudissements que de
siffler la seconde fait grincer des
dents
en effet au nom de la raison européenne
pierre bérégovoy annonce la plus forte
baisse d'impôts sur les parts de toute
la 5ème république qu'à six mois du
congrès socialiste cette raison accélère
les battements de coeur de bien des gens
de gauche
quant à la croissance économique
toujours très forte bien c'est une bonne
fée qui permet de financer en effet
dépenses supplémentaires création de
7800 postes de fonctionnaires et baisses
d'impôts mais la bonne fée a donnée à
pierre bérégovoy un gage davantage titre
iv de richesse
du coup pour certains il est devenu un
père un un père noël trop prodigue pour
d'autres il reste le père fouettard
gardien d'une rigueur que ceux ci
conteste le gouvernement au cours des
discussions budgétaires de bakil
accorder davantage de temps mon
fonctionnaires c'est la raison pour
laquelle il suit avec beaucoup
d'attention les événements de ce show
redoutant qu'ailleurs d'autres syndicats
sortent également et relais leur guise
voilà donc pour les éléments du budget
monsieur ministre bonsoir alors avant de
parler vraiment strictement du budget je
voudrais vous poser une question sur
peugeot puisque philippe terminer là
dessus le fait que monsieur calvet
tiennent vraiment les salaires et les
empêche de déraper ça vous arrange bien
au fond pour votre budget écoutez ce qui
n'arrangerait c'est que la discussion
s'engage
il faut des légumes d'une part et
d'autre on trouve une issue un conflit
une grève est toujours un événement
douloureux douloureux pour ceux qui y
participent et dangereux pour
l'entreprise il faut donc de part et
d'autre on discute en se disant que tout
n'est pas possible
mais ce qui est possible devrait être
faire alors on va parler du budget
maintenant philippe sassier wysiwys
chaleur certains disent que justement
vous n'avez pas suffisamment accorder de
choses dans ce budget certains ministres
socialistes disent que ce budget des
plus tout à fait ce qu'elle voulait
je viens de voir d'entendre les inquiète
mans votre commentaire pères fouettards
père noël
je crois que l'équilibré bien maintenu
ce budget est il socialiste c'est votre
question certains ne l'est pas il a été
préparé par un gouvernement dont le
premier ministre est socialiste
le ministre du budget michel charasse
est socialiste et je ne suis aussi avec
d'autres gouvernements qu'ils ne sont
pas mais qui approuve nous orientation
je dirais que c'est un budget de progrès
et un budget de justice qu'est-ce-qui de
quoi s'agit t il s'agit de préparer
l'avenir
c'était très bien dit éducation
nationale la recherche la culture
davantage d'epargne pour les entreprises
pour créer davantage d'emplois
c'est la priorité numéro un en étant
préparé l'avenir
c'est en étant le moteur de la
construction européenne et vous avez
noté ce qui est fait pour la baisse de
la tva pour ouvrir la france aux marchés
des capitaux
réduire les inégalités sociales nous en
avons pris plusieurs mesures la priorité
au rmi au logement social la baisse de
la taxe d'habitation bien d'autres
mesures que je ne détaille pas et enfin
réhabilité l'état oui il faut que l'état
assure ses missions mission de
solidarité missions de sécurité
d'événements tragiques viennent nous ont
rappelé la nécessité présence de la
france dans le monde
voilà ce budget alors la société n'est
pas socialiste mais nous avons une
volonté de transformation sociale dans
la liberté des acteurs économiques et
dans la solidarité
de telle sorte que les plus démunis
alors juste part de la croissance je
crois que ce budget correspond à cette
définition
alors vous le défendez très bien moi je
voudrais donner demandé 100 à votre
prédécesseur c'est le précédent ministre
de l'économie qui est en direct avec
nous en duplex cette fois c'est monsieur
edouard balladur alors je pense que
monsieur edouard balladur nous entends
bonsoir monsieur mini ou alors vous avez
entendu pierre bérégovoy qu'est ce que
vous pensez de son budget
si la vie pourquoi le cacher
je suis déçu par le budget qui nous est
présenté sur les objectifs
tous les français sont d'accord nous
devons entrer dans le grand marché
européen et nous nous on faire diminuer
le chômage
on n'en parle plus du chômage mais il ya
tout de même encore environ deux
millions et demi de français qui sont au
chômage
comment peut-on arriver à ces deux
résultats et bien en abaissant les
impôts il suffit de regarder ce qu'on
fait par exemple nos voisins allemands
pour se rendre compte que la baisse des
impôts le moyen le plus sûr de nous
préparer entrer dans l'europe et de
relancer davantage encore si possible ou
de faire durer la croissance ton
diminuer le chômage
d'où ma déception ma déception parce que
la france est un pays vont payer
beaucoup plus d'impôts de taxes et de
cotisations qu'en allemagne infiniment
moins est cependant les allemands vont
continuer à baisser leurs seins
davantage que nous ne faisons et je
crois que ce que fait le gouvernement
je dirais pour dire les choses de façon
simple que c'est la bonne direction mais
que c'est tout à fait insuffisant alors
serait pas avec les règles voire dre
deux fois plus de baisses d'impôts au
moins 30 milliards de baisses d impôts
comme nous l'avons fait durant deux
années que le gouvernement de jacques
chirac chaque année 30 milliards de
baisses désapprouvent cette année il y
en a à peu près que la moitié monsieur
balladur pierre bergoin veut vous
répondre je n'ai pas l'intention de
répondre monsieur balladur et encore
moins de polémiquer avec lui ils ont je
vais éclairer les français sur les choix
du gouvernement
d'abord je note que nous réduisons le
déficit budgétaire de 10 milliards et
nous baissons les impôts de 17 milliards
et pour le reste fils en sont les
priorités de l'avenir des accords que
j'ai avec monsieur balladur est simple
il concerne ce qui va nous permettre
d'entrer dans la décennie qui vient et
dans le 21e siècle l'éducation nationale
la recherche de la culture
y at il trop de crédit pour ces
postes-là la justice la défense
la gendarmerie y at il trop de crédit je
constate et je les observais cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale
c'est que personne ne nous propose
d'économies je considère donc que notre
budget fait la part équitable entre la
réhabilitation du rôle de l'état
beaucoup des difficultés que nous
connaissons dans la fonction publique
sont dus à la politique menée entre 86
et 88 et d'autre part des allègements
fiscaux qui permettent en effet réduire
les inégalités et d'encourager l'épargné
l'investissement pour lutter
efficacement contre le chômage merci
monsieur bérégovoy remercie monsieur
balladur nous aurons certainement
l'occasion de reparler tous ces sujets
avec l'un ni avec l'autre
je vous remercie d'avoir participé à ce
journal tous les deux alors voyons
maintenant rapidement d'autres
informations importantes de cette
journée de mercredi avec la halde
consignes et elle commence par la dure
journée inaugurale du tgv atlantique
il y avait trois tgv officielle pour
l'inauguration deux d'entre eux ont été
bloqués en gare du mans par des
manifestants protestations à l'appel de
la cgt contre les tarifs pratiqués sur
le nouveau tgv le troisième train en
provenance de paris s'est arrêté avant
le mans pour éviter d'être bloqués
buffet à l'arrêt en rase campagne pour
les invités et à montparnasse michel
rocard a procédé à l'inauguration
officielle
rangs derrière son devra attendre une
semaine la décision du tribunal de
commerce concernant la 5 décision
d'autoriser ou non la tenue d'un conseil
d'administration au fond duquel serait
nommé le nouveau président rachat par
rhône-poulenc de deux sociétés
américaines une filiale de rcz
corporation est un département de g1 est
ce pour un prix global de 8 milliards et
vu de france on ne pourra me devient
ainsi leader de plusieurs secteurs de la
chimie fine
toujours la tentative ou trois hommes
retiennent depuis cinq jours l'épousé
d'un banquier et ses deux enfants
aujourd'hui le père de philippe delaire
un des ravisseurs supplie son fils à la
télévision veut libérer ces otages
la suppression de la discrimination
raciale demeure l'un de nos objectifs
principaux
ainsi parlait ce matin frédéric de
claire le nouveau président sud africain
qui prêtait serment à l'église réformée
de pretoria le primat de pologne jozef
glemp en visite à bristol déclaré hier
soir après le communiqué du vatican
qu'un départ forcier les carmélites
d'auschwitz serait inacceptable fait il
se prononce tout de même en faveur de la
compression carmel hors du camp
à la bourse de paris après une petite
baisse l'indicateur de tendance reste
finalement parfaitement stable le dollar
8 fait ce vraiment si france 58 6 au
cours officiel en sport d'abord le
résultat de la course cycliste paris
bruxelles la victoire du hollandais
nijdam envoie les américains viennent de
gagner l'america's cup et oui c'est
surprenant parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
régate aujourd'hui mais le veto
américain à gagner sur le tapis vert la
justice américaine vient de trancher la
régate disputée en septembre 88 entre
américains et néo-zélandais est jugée
valable malgré la réclamation des
néo-zélandais le catamaran stars and
stripes et donc le premier multicoque a
remporté cette fameuse coupe de
l'america le cinéma maintenant avec la
sortie de tolérance un film au scénario
insolite et original cela se passe en
effet au xviiie siècle où la grande mode
à l'époque dans les salons c'était de
recueillir des ermites des hommes de
dieu des hommes d'église un peu
excentrique
alors on prenait le thé on discours est
avec eux c'était très très chic et dans
le film tolérance lhermitte est joué par
l'excellent comédien anglais rupert
everett nicole cornu langlois a pris le
thé avec lui
regardez bien cette ermite crasse venus
clandestinement d'angleterre est nommé à
ce féru earth c'est bien ce bout
comédiens très british qui dans le même
film devient séducteur machiavélique
pour mieux confondre ses hôtes décadent
voilà un petit monsieur ne travaille
pour les ermites et pau 2 de prier pour
les gens pour les aider d'aller au
paradis mais lui il réalisé que c'était
passé sur mon de prier pour des gens
dans ces familles là parce que c'était
trop féroce société féroce pour son
égoïsme cruel et ses excès gastronomique
je vous en prie ce sont simplement des
petits fours au fig
c'est une énorme farce sur l'absurdité
le dérisoire et l'intolérance à la fin
du xviiie siècle
si tu prends un homme passif religieux
et tu te mets dans une société agressive
et qu'est ce que peut être peut se
passer
serbie occupe devenir assassin il peut
devenir plus en plus intelligents que
tous les gens agressive aujourd'hui
et moi je pense que c'était un bon
investissement pour les gens aujourd'hui
c'est moins suivie
la crinière de votre homme voilà je vous
avant de refermer ce journal je vous
rappelle la principale information que
je vous ai donné au milieu du journal
dans la catastrophe du dc 10 de pia qui
s'est écrasé dans le désert il n'y a
aucun survivant comme nous l'indiqué
françois corner notre envoyé spécial et
comme l'a confirmé les premiers
sauveteurs arrivés sur les lieux du
drame
voilà fin de ce journal cette fois dans
un instant vous avez rendez vous avec
sophie davant pour une météo
n'oubliez pas ce soir 22 heures 10 la
nouvelle émission débat qui promet de
claude sérillon place publique consacré
ce soir à la chasse et puis vers minuit
le dernier journal sera présenté par
henri sannier bonne soirée sur antenne 2
à demain vapeur
oh